We are still pioneers, we've barely begun, our greatest accomplishments cannot
be behind us, because our destiny lies above us.
The initial impetus for the project of being to say, why not examine real possibilities?
Why not actually look at the real science there?
Luckily we had Kip and Kip is the foremost authority on all things gravitational.
The warping of space inside here scatters some of it back, blind scattering off with
the surface of a ripple ocean.
Neither wormholes nor black holes have been depicted in any Hollywood movie in the way that
they actually would appear.
This is the first time the depiction began with Einstein's general relativity equations.
The visual effects department under Paul Franklin and everybody at Double Negative took Kip's
mathematical data and they created real visual representations of what a black hole is meant
to look like.
The collaboration has produced visualization of things which no one had ever managed
to do before.
We've potentially may have discovered a couple of new things that were lurking there inside
the mathematics, inside the physics.
I worked out the equations that would enable him to do the gravitational lensing, so you
have light that comes from a star behind the black hole, it may come in, go around the
black hole several times and then come to the camera.
And so you wind up with several different images of the star.
The black hole warps the space so much, it just looks like you're looking at a strange
sort of funnel in the sky with this intensely black circle at the middle of it.
But the gravity of the black hole draws in all the matter from the surrounding universe.
And this spins out into a giant disc around the central sphere, and as it whirls in towards
the center, the gas gets hotter and hotter.
And this thing, the accretion disc around it shines brilliantly.
And then we found that if you then render this whole thing, you visualize it all through
this extraordinary gravitational lens.
The gravity twists this glowing disc of gas into weird shapes, and you get this extraordinary
sort of rainbow of fire across the top of the black hole.
And I saw this disc wrap up over the black hole and under the black hole, and I had known
it intellectually, but knowing it intellectually is completely different than seeing it, then
feeling it.
We had determined, when we started down this road, that if it didn't look like something
that would be comprehensible to the audience, we would have to manipulate it in some way.
But what we found was, as long as we didn't change the point of view too much of the camera
position, we could get some very understandable tactile imagery from those equations.
They were constantly surprising.
You know, spoke to the maxim that, you know, the truth can be stranger than fiction.
We're going to write several technical papers about this.
One aimed at the astrophysics community, and then it's something for the computer graphics
community, saying, here are some things that we've discovered about gravitational lensing
by rapidly spinning black holes that we never knew before.
So this collaboration isn't over until we've given some sense of the things that we've learned.